want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know you've got something more
inside you two you have michael jordan
level genius at something so today let's
live your best believe life and get some
incredible motivation from the one and
only jay shetty
enjoy
journaling can often be seen as a habit
that wastes time you're sitting there
writing when you could be doing
something but i find setting your
intention and setting your desire for
the day
is a much more powerful and practical
way to now walk into your day and feel
like you know why you're there
to feel a sense of purpose and so for me
setting an intention before a big
meeting before a difficult phone call
before an awkward conversation reminds
me of who i want to be in that
interaction
and that remembrance that confidence and
clarity around who i want to be allows
me to navigate those seemingly difficult
awkward moments that naturally arise
throughout the day so this is a time
that i take and as you can see from my
notes none of these are beautiful none
of these are perfect none of these are
fully aligned they are scattered
spontaneous sometimes random thoughts
and i allow myself to doodle squiggle
whatever it takes because that allows me
to feel that it's free-flowing stop
trying to make it perfect stop trying to
make it look amazing just make it the
way it allows you to feel like you have
a window into your mind and so when i
look at these notes i sometimes think
i'm just allowing myself to express
what's on my mind right now when i was
around 16 maybe 15 i we used to
celebrate christmas every year and
christmas is probably my favorite time
of year we were talking about it like i
love uh listening to christmas songs and
i love christmas decoration and for me
christmas is present it's presents and
and so i grew up in a culture where we
celebrated christmas but christmas was
presents and a family dinner
and because i went to my school in
england we'd celebrate all the religious
holidays so we knew about all the uh
main stories behind every major world
religion and so i remember celebrating
christmas at home but thinking i don't
know that much about jesus and should i
not be connecting with jesus because
that's why we even have this day and so
i started going to church in my local
area just out of curiosity i wasn't
trying to be a christian or trying to be
a hindu or trying to be anything i was
just
interested and curious
to be like what is it about christ that
created a day that has lasted thousands
of years that people all over the world
celebrate there must be something here
and so i feel like we get so scared
because we want clear designations we
want like a clear title of i am this or
i am that and that gives us a sense of
safety and security but really answers
come into curiosity not in the security
yeah right what does that identity do to
us in a good way or in a negative way in
a good way it creates a and this isn't
just about religious identity it's any
identity
but whatever yeah it's not about holding
on to this identity of yourself yeah so
in the good sense it surrounds you with
more people like that so if i'm a
podcaster i hang out with more
podcasters we learn more about
podcasting and that's a great thing
because we all become better podcasters
the mistake is i go oh i can only be a
podcaster but i can't write a book i
can't make a video i can't do that now
and that's the mistake that it makes so
it should be evolving these
titles that we give ourselves these
communities should help us evolve not
devolve yeah and and not stop us from
expanding and growing okay and and so
you want to be around people that are
always curious and insightful i first
learned about this through dan o'reilly
and his irrational labs where at an
event they encouraged us to ask more
vulnerable deep and bigger questions
how many of you are tired of small talk
how many of you start every meeting in
the same way hey how's it going yeah it
was good yeah you know same old weekend
yeah you know it's it's been a lot all
right let's get to work we literally
have the same conversation on repeat
almost seven times a day in every
meeting and guess what neither you nor
the other person enjoys that
conversation now this point also applies
whether you're working on zoom or
whether you're meeting in person again
with people we're so used to asking
someone how are you and it's kind of a
throwaway question people usually come
back and give us one of these five
answers good
bad okay fine or
we don't learn anything about the other
person we don't get an opportunity to
deepen our relationship and it's almost
like we didn't even care when we asked
the question
but what if we ask someone hey what's a
challenge that you've been working
through lately how can i help you
through it or what's something that
you're trying to overcome that you may
need an insight on
this type of question gives the person
an opportunity to really share what's
happening that vulnerability allows you
to build a deeper bond and deeper
connection and now you're actually
engaging with someone in a refreshing
way
now if you're like me and you're still
spending a ton of your time on zoom i
mean i'm recording podcasts and
interviews with some of my favorite
authors we recently had oprah on the
podcast about a new book what happened
to you and when i'm speaking to people
on zoom i found that it's even more
difficult to build rapport a connection
especially if you've never met them
before
in person
one of the ways i've been able to cross
this bridge is by being curious
but not creepy now what i mean by that
is about asking someone about something
that's in their background i think by
now everyone knows their zoom shot and
their zoom location they have a few
things in the background maybe a piece
of art and maybe a picture of their
family and this is such a beautiful
conversation starter especially if
you're trying to build a new
relationship recently i was on a call
with a client and i asked him about a
really interesting thing that he had
hung on his wall behind him it was a
paintbrush i was so fascinated that i
had to be curious not creepy and ask him
why he had it there he said my first
ever job when i was around 14 years old
is i used to paint fences
and after painting fences i got to paint
rooms and after painting rooms i got to
start painting homes and now he's an
executive and a director of a large
company and he said that he hangs this
paintbrush on his wall to remind him of
where he started give the person you're
speaking to an opportunity to tell you a
story i promise you'll be memorable and
meaningful and if not hopefully it makes
one of you laugh the reason why we
procrastinate is because we're left to
our own devices if i don't feel like
doing it i don't have to do it i can
procrastinate i can overthink i can get
distracted
when i really want to work on something
i find an accountability partner i've
had to do it with my health for a long
long time i don't enjoy working out
you've heard me say that before but i
want to be fit i want to be healthy and
i want to be alert and i know that
exercise is a big part of making that
possible i found an accountability
partner in my tennis coach she always
shows up she always shows up on time and
she will make sure i get there if i get
one of those excuses like oh i'm feeling
tired today or i'm a bit sore today
she'll make sure that i'm there playing
tennis no matter what knowing that
someone else is already out there when
it's cold when it's raining when it's
hot when they're tired allows you to
push yourself out of your comfort zone
when you really need to work on
something and improve something you
often have to do it when you don't feel
like doing it when you don't feel like
doing something it doesn't mean you
shouldn't do it because that's when you
have to connect with the feeling after
we get so obsessed about how we feel
before something when the feeling after
is that much more important before you
eat healthy food you might not be
attracted to it after you eat healthy
food you feel good about yourself but if
you see that burger you see those fries
or you see that chocolate fudge cake it
feels good before but then afterwards
you usually regret it words that we
should use
more of in our life
are words that
give us
the right feeling we want to feel so
i'll give an example
instead of saying now i work super hard
i do get tired
and i do get exhausted
sometimes
uh i'm very aware of it and i'm cautious
of it
and i realized that for a long time i
just kept repeating i'm tired i'm
exhausted i'm tired i'm exhausted and
i'd say to my wife i'd say to my team
overwhelmed i'm stressed yeah and i
still do it sometimes so it's not that
i'm perfect but you're making me aware
of it and i say that i started to
realize that okay it didn't make me feel
better by saying it and actually what i
was trying to do was get validation from
someone else to be like i know how hard
you work and you're amazing and blah
blah blah and so you know you're really
doing it for a reaction and then i
started to realize well
i am tired but why don't i just say
i'm going to make some time to nap today
uh i need to i need to find some time
today to rest
i need to make sure that i uh you know
get some time to myself today like when
you flip it not by just saying oh i feel
amazing because i don't feel amazing
again you don't lie to yourself but
you're trying to create words that help
you actually get what you need so me
saying i'm tired
really what i need to be saying is i
need to get some more rest today i
better sleep early and then you go all
right you know to rather you know what i
think i'm gonna sleep early tonight
that's that's perfect because now i'll
sleep early and i'll get the rest and i
won't be tired hey riley i'm so tired it
just creates this negative pattern of
complaining and whining we know that we
have around 60 to 80 000 thoughts per
day the most incredible thing is these
thoughts are cycling they're not only
repetitive but they're also negative
i realize that knowing which of the most
repetitive and negative thoughts allows
you to spot their trigger do you
experience this when you're on social
media do you experience this when you're
watching a particular show or you're
around certain people what we want to do
is find that trigger
trace that trigger back to its root and
reduce that activity in our life
often what we think is causing us
anxiety is different from the root of
where it started it was wayne dyer who
said when we change the way we look at
things the things we look at change
let's look at our thoughts differently
stop thinking that you are your thoughts
and that your thoughts are all you are
recognizing that we're so much more
beyond our thoughts allows us to
disconnect and distance from them and
then upgrade them towards healthier
thoughts how many of you have tried to
change everything all at the same time
you say to yourself i want to work on my
health i'm going to improve my career
i'm going to get promoted this year and
we're going to go on date night every
night you start getting fixated on
improving every area of your life it
comes from this desire to be better and
do more but the truth is
you have to choose that one big priority
it has to be not only at the top of the
list in the beginning it has to be the
list there is only one thing you can
improve at a time and you need to choose
wisely it's so easy to get caught up and
think i want to improve my career i also
want to learn more i also want to work
on my relationship i also want to work
on my health
we have to stop that and say this
is my big priority for the next 30 days
make your first step a small step you
may want to be up here but you need to
start down here you need to take the
first step the reason why most people
never get started is that their goal is
so big that they think they have to
achieve that on day one they think that
if they don't get there
they can't start here and this is the
most debilitating frustrating feeling
and that's why we have to simplify and
create that first small step reading is
one of my favorite things to do but
sometimes my stack of books that i want
to read is bigger than the amount of
time i have and at the same time i'm
trying to figure out which one am i
going to get the most value from and
often i'll overthink and procrastinate
so many friends will come to me and say
my partner doesn't spend enough time
or i don't have enough time
and what they're really saying is from a
partner point of view is
i really want energy
intimacy and presence and attention it's
attention you're not asking for time
you're asking for attention and i've had
friends who have gone on weekends away
with their partners and they'll come
back and their partner on monday morning
will say i wish we had more time
together and the partners thinking well
but we just spent the whole weekend
together but they're like no because you
were doing your work and by the beach
and you were reading your book and i was
trying to take care of the kids and you
realize it was never time it was
attention it was intimacy it was
presence
and so if we don't define those words
all right words are all about
definitions if you don't define them
people will break that contract and
their emotional contract and you have
nothing to hold them to turn off your
notifications and turn on chill relaxing
work music
i've done this for such a long time
where i have a playlist that i listen to
that allows me to just get into the zone
what i find music does especially
instrumental music that's what i focus
on i try to stay away from popular music
that i may listen to in the car or while
i'm in the gym what that does is it
gives the mind enough distraction enough
rhythm enough pattern enough momentum so
that you can actually focus your mind on
the activity at hand now some of you may
prefer silence or working to chatter and
that's fine too you can even put that
type of music on but for me instrumental
beats and rhythms are a fantastic way of
getting into the zone turning off your
notifications is just a no-brainer if
you're really trying to do some deep
work when you're with loved ones when
you're with family when you're with your
friends
make a vow to not use technology if you
need to have i've seen these around
where you have a technology jar and
everyone puts their phone in it at the
start of a dinner and takes it at the
end make a vow that when you're with
your friends when you're with your
family that you will not be on your
phone
and leave your phones in the same place
in one area so that none of you can just
get that sneaky moment i have to take a
look at it when you first start you may
be worried that you're going to be bored
of each other
you might even be worried well how's
this person going to compete with my
phone how are they going to entertain me
i mean my phone has access to every form
of entertainment
sit in that discomfort again
and in that discomfort you want to learn
something new about that person you're
going to become more curious your mind
actually has the opportunity to start
building a different bond earlier i
mentioned that you want to create no
technology times in your home you also
want to create no technology zones in
your home in mine and radhi's home those
spaces are the dining table and the
bedroom those are two areas that we want
to be technology free that we've
designated as important areas of
connection and so the dining table and
the bedroom becomes places and zones in
my home where we don't use technology
harvard did a table which i really
believe is what mindful speaking is all
about
so what is this so it's called the it's
called harvard list of emotions but i i
kind of change the name to emotional
vocabulary because i think it sounds
better
so an emotional vocabulary if you look
at all of the world's emotional
vocabulary it's very limited we use five
words to describe pretty much everything
good
bad yeah okay fine
so it's like how's your week going good
how's your day been bad how are you
feeling okay literally like we use such
limited words and that may be okay for
the majority of people
but in your personal relationships it's
so important to expand your emotional
vocabulary so this table that harvard
has made which anyone can find just by
typing in harvard list of emotions on
google
what that does is that it shows you that
when you say you're sad what do you
actually be in so it gives you all this
list of emotions that sit under the word
sad are you irritated are you offended
are you disappointed have you been let
down the more you expand your emotional
vocabulary the more you can diagnose how
you feel interesting and the more you
can tell your partner or your friend
this is how i'm feeling this is how i'm
actually feeling and and this is one of
the biggest mistakes with words is that
we think our words mean the same thing
now when you say love you might think
forever
and when i say love i might think for
tonight
right
and is literally how the word
love or care or marriage or
forever gets misused abused and thrown
about
because we both mean different things
and our meanings are based on our
backgrounds our beliefs our beliefs but
how we were born and how our
perspectives our culture experiences
everything yeah it forms our meaning so
i really believe that in a relationship
in our communication with words define
words
when you say yeah we're best friends or
friends what does that mean to you when
we're business partners what does that
mean to you a contract in a financial
legal sense is to define the terms right
but in our emotional sense we also need
to define the terms and we don't do that
emotionally enough and that's why we
feel emotionally like someone broke the
contract
and you have nothing to hold them to
because you never made a contract
you never communicated you never
communicated the meaning of these words
exactly and that's why words are so
powerful but they're only powerful when
we agree on the definition if you're
someone who finds that you're always
procrastinating you're always over
analyzing overthinking and you're
struggling to get stuff done
this video is for you the first step is
identifying why we procrastinate how
many of you have ever wondered why do i
overthink i want to get this done i want
to make progress in my life but for some
reason i just can't seem to stop
alexander rosenthal who's a
procrastination researcher explains the
four types of trigger we procrastinate
because of expectancy value time or
impulsivity people procrastinate because
of a lack of value associated with the
task
or because they expect that they're not
going to achieve the value they're
trying to achieve
or because the value is too far from you
in terms of time and finally because
you're very impulsive as a person what's
interesting about understanding where
your procrastination comes from is that
it allows you to understand what the
challenge is and what the issue is
without blaming yourself without
thinking that something is wrong with
you and actually the clearer you get
about the value you're going to get from
the task the amount of time you do have
to dedicate to it don't judge yourself
so many of us when we procrastinate and
overthink start to feel that there's
something wrong with us
we judge ourselves we make ourselves
feel guilty we say negative things about
ourselves to ourselves and to others we
start saying things like i'm so lazy i'm
so worthless i'm not good enough i'm not
smart enough this doesn't make you more
productive more proactive or more
effective how many times is putting
yourself down made you lift yourself up
i don't think those two things go
together what ends up happening is that
when we judge ourselves for being
procrastinators we create a prison of
guilt
this becomes a space that we actually
can't break out of and it's how
procrastination keeps us trapped by
making us believe that we can't do
anything that we're no better so we need
to stop judging ourselves how do we stop
judging ourselves by letting go
realizing that we all make mistakes and
that we're going to leave that all
behind and we're going to turn over a
fresh page that we're going to start
anew when i'm having a productive
effective day that doesn't mean i don't
get distracted i get distracted plenty
of times i have tons of notifications
social media big announcements things
that are happening throughout the day
plus a team across the world in
different time zones to manage so when i
get distracted i've created a really
healthy
relationship with distraction i feel
like sometimes our relationship with
distraction is quite negative we see it
as a bad thing we judge ourselves for
feeling distracted we start saying oh i
wish i was more focused or i wish i was
more effective
so i literally got one of these
distraction timers as i call it and i
turn it over as soon as i get distracted
i let the sand run out and as soon as it
runs out i have to get back to my task
this gives me the space and the time to
allow for little distractions and now i
figured out a way to allow myself five
minutes of distraction time every hour
so every hour i allow myself to browse
on my phone for two to five minutes and
that way i know that that time is going
to happen that time is going to come and
that allows me to delay it to put it off
and to postpone my own distraction this
story was about the journey of a person
and this person came across a tumultuous
river
when they saw this river they knew that
if they set foot inside this river they
would get dragged away with the current
they realized that they would have to
build somewhat of a vehicle or mode of
transport to get to the other side they
started to get a log
and they thought maybe that was enough
and they pushed it out onto the water
and
the water just completely took away the
log they then realized they would have
to build something a lot more stable
they got some bamboo they created two
rows they tied it up with some rope they
even built an ore they got on top and
they started to paddle with all their
strength and all their energy
and finally they made it to the other
side
this person thought to themselves i can
never
live without this raft
this saved my life this raft is the
reason i'm alive so they strapped it to
their back and decided to take it
wherever they went they started to walk
through the forest
but they realized it was difficult to
maneuver because the
raft just kept getting stuck in between
the trees and they're trying to pivot
and maneuver and try and navigate
through but the rafters just getting
chipped and broken and they could either
continue to try and struggle through
with the raft on their back or
they could put the raft down
and walk through freely so often what's
causing us anxiety is what we're holding
on to
our views of what is normal what we
expect what we want to happen the
picture we're projecting when you're
holding on tightly to something that is
slowly being pulled out of your hands it
causes you even more pain and anxiety
what is it that you need to let go of
to reduce your anxiety thoughts are
meant to be spotted
stop and reflect and then swap and what
i mean by that is
if you've got a thought that's repeating
like you said and is negative i'm
guessing you don't want that thought
around for too long
so you want to spot when does that
thought arrive does it arise when i'm
with certain people does it arise when
i'm on a particular social media
platform does it arise when i go to a
particular place
where is that what is the seed of that
thought right so once i had identified
that i now need to stop spend some time
in stillness and go is this thought
benefiting me
is this thought useful to me is this
thought actually leading me to who i
want to become and if it's not i need to
swap it with a thought so one of my
favorite ways of let's take an example
of like
i feel less than i feel
uh like i'm not achieving anything i'm
not good i'm no good i'm not good enough
so you spot that and you go i always
feel that when i'm going through this
particular instagram profile because i'm
looking at someone who i think is better
than me okay what do i swap that with
you don't swap that with you're
beautiful you're amazing you're
incredible because you may not believe
that yet yeah but you stop it you you
swap it with i feel confident when
i feel attractive when i feel happy and
joyful when and you figure out what is
that thing that i need to be and do to
feel that emotion the best place to talk
about that though with thoughts is the
movie inception
so you look at how a thor is planted
into someone's mind
and how in that movie leonardo dicaprio
in his wife's mind plants a thought
that this is not real
and that thought grows into a belief
belief that is so strong it's crazy
right and it's like that is literally
what a thought can do and you see that
in the joker movie
so i i did a whole episode last year
which is all about like mental health
and the joker and you look at the joker
stories he's trying to bring joy to
others but everyone treats him badly and
so the thought sets in if i'm not worthy
i'm not valuable my father doesn't want
me
no one thinks i'm funny everyone
makes fun of me even when i go on tv
everyone's laughing at me
that idea becomes his reality now i get
that that's a fiction movie but the
point is still that we see even in
today's world
that thoughts have the ability to become
i i forget the word that leonardo
dicaprio uses the movie but that thought
yeah cancer or sometimes yeah it's like
a cancer in the mind right it like
really just expands and so i think we
have to be so good at spotting stopping
and swapping thoughts i think actions
that we should be adding more of in our
life are
actions that
create positive habits i think it has to
be habits orientated it has to be stuff
that we can repeat
and and
in think like a monk i talk about the
four key habits in your day which are
thankfulness
inspiration
meditation and exercise which is the
acronym of time
so make more time in your day for
thankfulness inspiration meditation and
exercise those are four actions that i
think if everyone wants to take in their
day
this is what happens when you're
thankful
you boost your immunity you boost your
self-confidence
you boost your mood yeah because you go
oh people love me that means i matter
people care about me that means i have
something to care about so it boosts
your mood and then when you tell people
that you're thankful you know boost
connection and relationship and when you
thank someone you now boost the feeling
of i have people in my life that care
about me and i care about them so much
comes out of that one action inspiration
or insight listening to a podcast
reading a book reading a quote when you
do that again you feel excited you feel
enthused you feel like you're learning
you feel like your mind actually works
and that they can go somewhere so that's
a great action meditation of course
we've talked about at length in the
beginning and exercise
people just don't understand that we
could solve so many of our
challenges simply by sleep and exercise
and diet like those three things change
your life should change your life and
and we have to just get focused on one
at a time
and so what in actions i i talk about
this thing in principle is we want
things to be small steps but big
priorities so if you want to change an
action in your life it needs to be a big
priority and then you need to break it
down into small steps what we try and do
is we try and change everything at the
same time all of us don't have a lot of
time and so one of the reasons we
procrastinate is because we say well i
don't have enough time to figure that
out so i'm just going to put it off i'll
do it next week i'll do it tomorrow i'll
think about it later because we don't
think we have the right amount of time
here's what i've realized and here's a
hack that has helped me break through
that idea i've realized that when i'm
present and focused that's more powerful
than any amount of time when i'm alert
when i'm ready even if i'm there for 15
or 20 minutes i can actually make more
progress than if i had an hour and i
didn't bring my best energy
ask yourself consistently how can you
bring your presence to the task not your
time don't let time be the limiting
factor
now it all gets real how much is fast
and how much where am i where are my
faucets
where am i attached to i feel like
that's the only thing that's attaching
us to the zip line
just that one hook
don't think about it
oh my god it all gets real now
you're literally only hooked to one
thing i don't where am i meant to uh how
far should i be am i doing this right
okay no there's two hooks that's good
what do you think i think you should
have gone first because you're looking
at it okay i know i know
i feel like i need the toilet
yeah
okay oh god cool
bob if you don't want to do it i don't
want you to do it is it no it's fine no
if you don't feel comfortable i'm fine
are you sure
[Laughter]
are you just gonna push me how is this
working just meditate right are you sure
i'm fasting properly
ready keep your legs straight and hold
your harness yeah okay
once you're past this building you can
open your arms i don't want to i'm not
opening my eyes this view is beautiful
spectacular i'm okay
oh no am i going
when do we go okay you can give us a
countdown
give me a counter can we cut them down
guys
ready
i'm not oh god oh god
[Music]
ah
wow
[Applause]
that was amazing
you made it really i did but i had my
eyes closed 99 of the time
you're not gonna lie
you did it though i did it you did it
that initial bit was scary but this was
always the initial of it
i started turning sideways
i'm good man i'm good it was amazing it
was a lot of fun
i always thought that we wasted time
because we were lazy or we were
indecisive and while some of these
things may be true for you there
actually is a deeper reason why we feel
that way one of my favorite books is
called flow i was recently rereading it
on the blinkist app flow talks about
flow state which is experienced by
musicians rappers singers athletes when
they're in the zone when they're
performing at such a high level they
even forget space time and everything
around them and you get to see art or
magic in real life now there are a lot
of amazing lessons inside flow but one
of my favorite ones is this discussion
when you're looking at skills versus
challenges how many of you have ever
felt that you don't have the best skills
in an area and the challenge feels
really high chances are if you've
experienced that you end up feeling
frustrated or stuck and disappointed in
yourself and that's one of the reasons
why you start overthinking and
procrastinating you don't have the
skills you have a challenge or a goal
that set really high and now you feel
overwhelmed and overburdened by the
height of that target that you just give
up and stop working
sometimes we have the opposite
experience where our skill is really
high but actually we haven't looked at
our challenges we've been doing the same
thing over and over again we've been
repeating the easy win and in that
situation we sometimes feel bored lost
or confused we feel like our life
doesn't have meaning it doesn't have
purpose and there's nothing exciting or
thrilling about the work that we do the
author goes on to say that flow is
achieved when our skill
meets our challenge
so when we really want to experience
that flow state being in the zone
feeling that momentum feeling that
energy thriving we have to make sure
that our skill and challenges match are
we feeling frustrated and stuck because
our skills are too low and our
challenges are too high or are we
feeling bored because our skills are too
high and our challenges are low
in either case we want to focus on
either increasing our skills or
increasing our challenge
that helps us focus on the area that we
actually need to have an impact and we
stop wasting time with all the
distractions so now instead of
procrastinating and overthinking we
start focusing on a list of things that
can help us improve our skills you have
books
coaching mentors communities courses all
of these are phenomenal ways to start
learning now if you're someone who needs
to increase your challenge your
challenge can be increased through
networking i remember when i used to
speak or get invited to speak at
colleges and schools i love that
experience i still do it today whenever
i can but at one point i realized i
wanted to stretch my comfort zone then i
started working with corporate companies
because i really wanted to help
organizations build new models of
thinking today i work with so many
fortune 500 companies and enjoy the
experience deeply but i also wanted to
extend my challenge beyond that i
started speaking on stages i started
speaking at my own events what i found
is that you can extend
your challenge by increasing your goals
or targets
or by changing the scale or the depth
sometimes we challenge ourselves by
trying to affect more people do more
things and sometimes we challenge
ourselves by going deeper in the areas
we're already in and finally a new way
of challenging yourself is a new
industry when you think about someone
like michael jordan who went off to play
baseball or you think about steve jobs
who went into movies and pixar and
animation
people have challenged themselves across
industries when they've truly mastered
their field so the question i want you
to answer is this instead of
procrastinating and overthinking do you
need to work on your skills or do you
need to work on your challenges and
you'll know where to start and i think
in our limited mindset sometimes we
think that detachment means indifference
or detachment means disconnecting
and actually detachment
means and i and i quote
um
this this incredible writer where he
said that
detachment doesn't mean that you own
nothing
detachment means that nothing owns you
and when you look at detachment through
that lens it means can i use everything
that i have
for a higher purpose can i use it and
engage it rather than be consumed and
used by it now granted that's a very
high platform to live on and it's not
easy but the point being that detachment
is not indifference that detachment
doesn't just mean oh i don't want
anything to do with this it's actually
how can i use this
for more than what it's being used for
right now
and that's what's known as by rupa
goswami
he's
he quotes a about probably about 500
years ago
he created and coined a term called
yukta vairagya which means using
everything for a higher purpose
so he talks about how real renunciation
real detachment real aestheticism is how
can i use this for something more than
myself and it's not about just getting
rid of it i love that principle and i
think that that's a very
that's a very practical principle that
we can all employ living in the real
world so for monks detachment is real
like we didn't have beds right we didn't
have a place that we slept we slept in a
different place every night but if
you're not a monk and you want to apply
that same principle this is how you
think about it you recognize that i
don't want to be in a position where i
am consumed by everything another
addition to detachment is
detached from the result focused on the
process that's another definition in the
bhagavad-gita that you're not attached
to the fruits of your labor but you're
completely committed to the labor the
process itself and that's something that
we miss so often that we think being
detached means not caring about what
happens actually it means caring about
the process and not caring about the
result so when we're talking about
writing a book and you know you've
written books and when you're writing a
book
if you're writing a book and all you're
thinking about is how many copies am i
going to sell
now you're not going to write a good
book no you're dead out of the gate
totally you're dead straight away
because all you're thinking about how
many copies am i going to sell is this
going to rank if that's what you're
thinking about you're now not present
which means you're not going to write a
good job a good book whereas if you were
dedicated to the process
the result is a given the results are
natural end to dedicated to the process
there's a difference between a lack of
expertise and inexperience
right we think we lack expertise in
something but actually we're just
inexperienced at it
and and that's the point of that second
element of
you don't have to be the best at
something when you start doing it but as
soon as you start doing it you've now
given yourself that opportunity to grow
and and i think we all know this there's
always something we've all learned and
become better at it but if you're
fascinated by you're probably more
likely to invest more time right and so
yeah don't but it is also important
there may be things in your life that
you have an expertise in but you don't
have a passion in but then ask yourself
the question
why don't i have a passion here because
you could add meaning to it
like there are so many skills that we
have that if you added a bit of meaning
you added some purpose to it you added
why you were doing it you could actually
find a great use for it and i think a
lot of us are under under
underestimating how powerful expertise
is you may have strengths that are just
underutilized by your current job but
actually could be really well utilized
by someone that you felt activated you
one of my biggest beliefs
and i read this study that inspired my
beginning and it was that the most
successful people in the world
healthy wealthy or wise choose education
over entertainment
and the most unsuccessful people in the
world unhealthy unwealthy or unwise
choose entertainment over education
so i made it my mission in life
to build entertainment first content
with an educational heart
and i was thinking how do we make wisdom
spread at the pace people want
entertainment
how do we meet people where they are so
that they can come on a journey with us
how do we meet people because guess what
hundreds of thousands of people will do
courses millions of people will come to
events but billions will always watch
television
and network tv and online programming
how do we meet people there
so a big part of my vision and goal is
to create conscious content
that will sit on all the platforms that
everyone binge watches will be extremely
entertaining that you won't even know
but it will have the most meaningful
messages behind it one of my favorite
ways to deal with success is continue
trying to be
the least successful person
in the room that you and i think there's
those statements of like you know that
would be the dumbest person yeah that
would be the smartest person in the room
etc and i think it's the same with if
you become successful
don't just stand at the top of the
mountain don't just stand at the top of
the building
go back down the stairs and and keep
building and keep living as that person
that got you there because you only got
there because you started from the
bottom
right no one starts at the top and so
you started at the bottom and you built
it up and it was that mindset that you
started with that got you there and so
you want to keep rediscovering that
mindset and new parts of it they're new
parts of that mindset too
where you're always trying to challenge
yourself and so for me one of the best
ways of dealing with success is keep
expanding the goal posts
right keep widening the goal post keep
making them
harder to reach and challenging yourself
because when you challenge yourself
and you push yourself out of your
comfort zone you're naturally humbled
because you're naturally humbled when
you're walking into space and i'm sure
you feel this sometimes like sometimes i
walk in a room and i'm like how did i
even get here yeah right like sitting on
a table i'm like i'm the why should i be
here yeah like and there's part of it
that's impostor syndrome and that can
have its own negativity but part of that
just lets me feel like a beginner again
and i appreciate that feeling and i go
this is amazing because learning to be
grateful
and stop just thinking that oh i earned
all of this and i did it all myself and
i'm self-made you start recognizing
gratitude for all the people that got
you there so for me in success first
thing is be grateful for all your
teachers mentors guides people that got
you there the second thing is always
keep challenging yourself because the
more you're out of your comfort zone the
more naturally you stay humble you don't
stay humble by trying to be humble you
become humbled constantly right but
trying to do stuff that's out of your
league which constantly makes you
prepare
work deepen
all that stuff all of that stuff that
makes you go there again and then the
third thing you do with success is i
think you try and share it with others
you try and use your platforms as an
opportunity to give other people a
platform yeah so that they can come up
as well because you're reminded of what
a beautiful gift you have in the book i
talk about how it's about training your
mind for peace and purpose every day and
that's the peace part that's how you
find peace in difficult times you
recognize it's part of the process but i
always like to offer the service element
too which is the future part the purpose
part it's
i would think about the year 2030
or 20 50 whichever year
you you want to meditate on 10 years
time 30 years time
and think about your kids or your
grandkids or young people around your
nieces and nephews if you don't have
kids
people around you they'll be going to
school and they'll be learning about
2020 in their history books
and let's say that one of their teachers
assignments
is you have to go back to your parents
or grandparents and ask them
what were they doing in 2020
so imagine now you're sitting at a
dining table in 2030 or 2050 your kids
or your grandkids collecting your mom
dad dad mom dad dad mom mom
no dad no mom i don't know what the
language is going to be there
and you just say to your parents they
say
uh
what what did you do in 2020
and whatever answer you want to give
them in 10 or 30 years time
just do that today and that will
literally clear your mind because as
long as you can give them an answer in
10 to 30 years time that you're going to
be happy with just saying you know what
we just stuck together and we got
through it you know what i i got i
became an activist and i really
supported this you know what we just
doubled on our business to make sure we
we didn't let go of anyone and we made
sure all of our teams were well taken
care of whatever answer you you want to
give in 10 20 years time that question
will give you so much clarity and that
will be the thing that pulls you through
this time rather than you feeling like
you're pushing through it with this
principle it was actually a study by amy
versniewski and her team at the yale
school of management they wanted to go
and research what they believed was the
most difficult job in the world
hospital cleaners and this was
pre-pandemic
these were people who had to clean up
the hospital rooms hospital beds
hospital toilets after people ate and
even often people passed away you can
only imagine what a challenging and
difficult job it is they went and
interviewed some hospital cleaners some
of them described themselves as cleaners
they described the activities that i
just stated and described themselves as
doing that kind of labor now another
group of hospital cleaners they
described themselves as healers
servers carers transformers they did the
same exact work as the other cleaners in
the same hospitals but they saw
themselves as directly connected towards
the healing journey of the patient and
the patient's family they saw their work
that if they could make an environment
clean that that would be better for the
patient and the patient's family they
saw it as a way of serving
someone's journey towards healing this
mindset which amy vs new scanner team
called job crafting is where you look at
your work differently so many of us get
caught up on that excel spreadsheet we
get caught up on that powerpoint
presentation we get caught up on doing
the actual task
but we forget to look up
look beyond our laptops look beyond our
screens zoom out and think about the
impact that our work actually has on
others
your work may be allowing you to put
food on the table and take care of your
family it may be helping your children
go to a specific school it may be
helping them have certain opportunities
when you look up from the task and you
focus on what your work truly allows you
and the people you love to do
you start looking far beyond
than just that activity think about that
today zoom out and that reduces the
anxiety it reduces the stress that is
attached to the day-to-day task
and allows you to look at it from a
bird's-eye view decision fatigue now i
want you to take a moment
to just jot down what are the decisions
you make every morning before you've got
out of bed
before you get into your commute or
start your work day chances are you
spend a lot of time thinking about what
to wear what to eat that morning you
might even think about what to eat for
lunch what to eat for dinner you might
be wondering around what movie you're
going to watch tonight what episode of
which show you're going to watch when
you get back you may even be thinking
about what meeting do i have what person
do i have to connect with today what do
i even have to do today these are very
common things for a lot of us the
concept of decision fatigue teaches us
that so many of us are making so many
insignificant decisions in the morning
that by the time we start our work day
we're already exhausted from making
decisions we overthink about the smaller
things that should be easy and now we
have no energy for the bigger things
that do require our attention and our
awareness i want you to create a table
of decisions to make the night before
and decisions to make the day off what
that's going to help you do is give you
something to focus on the night before
so you can be prepared and well ahead of
schedule before the next day and be
really clear about what you can only do
on that day now the night before you
want to be doing that either at the end
of your work day or just after dinner
the reason is because at the end of your
work day you can set yourself up for
success the next day for those of you
that want to leave it till after dinner
the reason why i say after is because we
make better decisions when we're eaten
and when we've nourished so what we're
essentially doing with decision fatigue
is that we're stopping ourselves from
over thinking about the smaller
irrelevant to some degree insignificant
decisions to the more significant
decisions now i'm not saying that eating
food is not important i'm not saying
that what you wear every day is not
important i take pride in what i eat and
what i wear but when i've meal prepped
when i've made a plan a week in advance
when i've made it simple for myself my
brain gets capacity and space to make
these big decisions a really great
example of this is mark zuckerberg
barack obama and others who've been
known to wear the same suits or the same
clothes again and again on repeat now
this is something i personally had
firsthand experience of living as a monk
every day we woke up and we wore robes
we had two sets one to wear one to wash
it simplified that energy in the morning
now today of course i don't wear robes
if not a monk anymore and i have a
wardrobe that i enjoy but inside of it i
have many different things but i have
them in many different colors that way i
still have somewhat of a uniform that
simplifies that or i make a decision the
night before i think the first thing we
have to do with beliefs is you have to
realize everyone has them it's not like
you don't have beliefs just because you
don't know what they are everyone has
beliefs that they're currently living
with and i think life is about
unlearning the beliefs you have and
questioning the beliefs you have and
then creating new ones so the first
thing i do is learning yeah from the
beginning from the beginning what if
your parents had their answers and the
way and the religion and this should we
be questioning it i think we should
question it because questioning the okay
questions
are
the most powerful invention
in the world
because questions either strengthen or
weaken a belief
based on the information so questions
aren't always from a place of doubt and
cynicism and trying to find a weakness
questions are a sincere request to
figure out something like when we're
sitting in these interviews you're not
sitting there trying to like be cynical
or be you want to help yourself and
people who are listening and watching
and so that's a question first of all a
question is not to
catch someone of god a question is not
to put someone down a question is not to
mislead people a question is to uplift
yourself and others and when you ask a
question in that way
the answer can either strengthen a
belief you already have or weaken it or
introduce you to a new one we've defined
our identity by our belief so imagine
you're on one of these assault courses
and you're on this rope and you're being
told to swing to the next rope
but in order to catch the next rope you
need to let go of this rope
but you're scared because this rope is
currently your safety so your current
belief is your safety
and when you have to consider holding on
to another belief and to entertain both
together you're scared that if that one
doesn't hold i'm basically going to fall
so people are scared that their belief
is currently their safety net and so
even if it's wrong it still makes them
feel safe and they feel comfortable and
we don't want to feel uncomfortable so
we'd rather hold on to that safety net
right so the only way to do it how do we
get comfortable with questioning our
beliefs but not being like
holding on to nothing well realizing
that you don't have to
change your mind or you don't have to
leave what you think
in order to entertain or be curious
about anything and explore like
exploring experimenting
and experiencing
can either strengthen the belief you
have or help you find a new one but you
have to do that middle three ease of
explaining exploring experimenting and
experiencing yeah and the problem is
that we are just theoretically thinking
we're not experiencing the benefit i
want you to start creating a five minute
gap between each and every meeting in
your schedule so if a meeting finishes
at 10 a.m the next one starts at 1005. i
don't want you to schedule any meetings
back to back from this point onwards you
may think five minutes is not a lot of
time but that five minute gap can be
life-changing here's how when you take
out time between each meeting you get
that really important time to decompress
and prepare for the next meeting you're
now not shifting your energy from one
thing to another thing to another thing
straight away and feeling like you're
just stressed in between not even
getting time to comprehend what the next
meeting is about i've got five habits
for you that you can do across five
minutes that are going to keep you
feeling productive effective and focused
on your well-being throughout the day
the first one is water it is so
important that we take a moment to
rehydrate between meetings it's so
important to stay hydrated because we
need to be drinking around two to three
liters a day and when we're doing that
it boosts our brain function it allows
us to feel clearer it's fantastic for
making us feel energized throughout the
day the second thing you're going to do
in your five-minute gap is walk around
this could be in your bedroom in your
kitchen wherever you get a moment it's
really really important to get moving so
many of us are feeling so stagnant and
stuck at the moment because we're
sitting at our desks all day long we no
longer have a lunch to get up to or a
meeting on the other side of our offices
to meet someone we're in the same place
this is causing a lot of issues with our
posture the way our body feels the way
our muscles are it's not natural for us
to be locked into a sitting position
throughout the whole day the third is to
watch by watch i mean watch a view
a window look out of a window look into
the sky
take a step out for a moment and get
some fresh air it's so important that we
look out into the distance we've got so
used to just staring at screens and
devices and books and schedules that are
right up in our face that we're not
giving our eyes the opportunity to look
out into the distance now this fourth
one's a little more interesting and you
may need a little bit more time for it
but it's the idea of wonder allow your
mind to wonder allow it to think of a
new idea to be creative to think about
something unrelated this is where
creativity comes from this is where that
feeling comes from that you're
innovating that you're allowing your
mind to connect dots that otherwise you
might seem as disconnected and the fifth
and final thing that you can do in those
five minutes is to wind down and one of
the best ways to wind down
is through your breath
allow yourself a few moments to breathe
in for the same amount of time as you
breathe out a very simple way to do this
is breathe in for a count of one to four
and breathe out for a count of one to
four how many of you ever felt that your
mind is ahead of your body your mind is
racing around but your body feels
sluggish and tired if you want to bring
your body and mind back into sync back
into alignment you want to breathe in
and breathe out for the same amount of
time doing this breathing practice
allows you to walk in with a clear mind
with a relaxed body and reduces your
anxiety throughout the day when you look
at material society and our world we're
always fixated on the output and the
result and the goal
and the monk mindset is really focused
on the input the process and the
day-to-day habits and the now
and that's not me saying we shouldn't
have goals i have goals too but what i'm
saying is that often that part can seem
very uncertain right right now
it's hard to set goals uh results are
uncertain and the future is uncertain
and the monk mindset actually starts
from the back and goes wait a minute
it's actually our input our intention
our current process that creates the
future that we need and want and yes
there are everyday things like where the
kids are going back to school whether
our jobs are coming back that and you
know me and brenda were talking about
this earlier and brendan has as a fairly
large company i have a smaller company
but there's people that are dependent on
me and families and things like that and
so
when i think about all of that stuff i
realized that all i can get certain
about
is putting my next step forward
and i think it's kind of like when
you're walking
you've become so comfortable walking you
don't even realize but actually all
you're doing is putting your next step
right you can't think about what's gonna
happen in a hundred steps time because
you haven't walked over the ground then
you don't know how the ground is gonna
change
so for me the monk mindset is how do i
just place this next step not perfectly
but how do i place this next step with
my best intention process and habits
possible and what does that require that
requires me
to be connected internally to my
internal guide and what does that
require it requires me to find that
stillness in space so i can actually
listen 75 of people feel they're not
living to their creative potential
75 of us it's huge three-quarters of us
believe that we're not tapping into our
creative potential now what does that
mean does that mean that we don't have
enough opportunities to be creative does
that mean we're not creating
opportunities to be creative creativity
allows us to express ourselves it allows
to bring out the fire in our soul that
artistic nature that ability to create
that we all have inherently within us
and allows us to bring that out in a way
that other people can appreciate it that
other people can value it so creativity
can change our relationships it can
spark inspiration it can spark thought
in every day life great quote by steve
jobs where he said that creativity is
simply connecting things and he said
that if you ask a creative person how
they did something they almost feel
guilty because it just felt obvious it
feels easy because all they did was
connect one dot to another dot and
that's what creativity is if you look at
technology today even if you look at
something like facebook we're all tuned
in through facebook if you think of the
word facebook facebook started out as
something that everyone would get at the
end of their year in college or
university which would be a facebook a
book of faces right that's one thing now
the idea is oh now we can be online
let's connect that idea online let's
take it online
i've just shared a quote from steve jobs
where he talked about creativity is just
about connecting things so victor if you
want to escalate if you want to make
your ability to create exponential you
need to be creating or connecting more
things to connect more things you need
to expose yourself to more experiences
more people more thought processes that
often seemingly don't relate when they
did a study harvard researchers did a
study on 3 000 executives over a period
of six years and they mapped what was
the most number one skill for the
differentiator between innovators
creatives and non-creatives there was
one thing that stood out that one thing
was associating associating the ability
to find associations patterns rhythms
symphonies
in seemingly unrelated topics ideas
opinions and people
epitome of that steve jobs was able to
make calligraphy relevant to designing
computers i think one of my first things
in failure
is
don't take it more personally than it
actually is and i'll give an example of
that when i was applying to
40 companies that all rejected me before
an interview yeah
all i was getting was an automated
response
saying your application will not go any
further
i can't take that personally because
they didn't meet me in person they
didn't have a
interaction with me they just saw my
name they saw i'd been a monk for three
years
that resume is useless i mean what's
your transferable skills like sitting in
silence and stillness yeah surprise
surprise no one wants to hire a monk and
so they rejected you but that's not
personal because they didn't meet me in
person and so there's a beautiful uh
meditation that i talk about in the book
which is called a question meditation it
was probably one of my favorite
techniques that i learned
and often when we ask questions brendan
to the world at least or to the universe
they're often demands they're not
questions they're like why is this
happening to me you know that's not a
question that is a
that is pain
uh a question is the way you're asking
me questions
jay i'm really curious how does this
work it's it's what's known as a sincere
request
or or
or a deep intention right and so a
question meditation is i want you to sit
with the question that causes you
anxiety and pain and i want you to ask
it
with sincerity with genuineness with
love and understanding and i want you to
allow yourself to not force the question
to come the answer to come to you in
that moment but allow yourself to
discover the answer throughout the day
and just sit with it if you sit with it
sincerely i guarantee you there will be
someone something that happens in the
day could be a message a billboard you
see and it will just shift the way you
start seeing
uh intervention divine intervention
everywhere in your life and that's you
know it really works so i would just say
sit with that question one of the
biggest mistakes we make is we don't
study the stories of the greats
so how many people's lives have you
studied from start to finish yeah if
you've studied someone's life from start
to finish i genuinely believe this is
like the core skill that's needed i
would say that the people i admire i
have studied their lives from start to
finish i know why they made bad
decisions what they consider to be good
decisions like there's autobiographies
and biographies out there there's
podcasts like hours where people come
and listen to people's stories if you've
not studied
someone's story
then you can't follow that path because
every time you hit a rejection so every
time i get rejected i think of steve
jobs getting kicked out of his own
company crazy every time i fail i think
about michael jordan losing a game every
time i get tired of training i think
about cristiano ronaldo putting in that
extra rep those are the visual cues that
we need but you only get those visual
cues if you've done the research and the
study and then you go
oh if steve jobs was kicked out of his
own company but then still had the
audacity at one point to go and build
pixar then i think i'm all right if i
just didn't get this job we don't have
to wait to have to experience a
near-death experience to have stillness
right but that stillness you experienced
so much stillness
and space and silence because you were
so in your moment and in that body where
everything was revealed to you and
that's what you went through
and i'm not saying that you can
manufacture that that is very unique to
brenda but what i am saying is if you
sit with yourself
every single day and be present with
your body and mind they will inform you
when people do this they say to me yeah
i've had a backache for probably six
months now i didn't notice it till now
or or jay you know what actually i just
really found this new idea that's gonna
change my business because the answers
are there inside of you but because we
don't sit with ourselves enough
and there's a beautiful statement in the
buddhist tradition the tibetan buddhist
tradition that says what movement does
for your body
stillness does for your mind
just think about what movement does for
your body the energy the expansion the
confidence that's what stillness does
intuition comes
from asking yourself
questions
basic questions simple questions just as
it would getting to know rich getting to
know jay is the same process
after i eat something did i like that
did i not like it the next morning did i
like that did i not like it when you ask
people what are your favorite movies you
know how you feel when you walk outside
a movie no you don't need to do a
personality test you don't need to do a
three months away and cost a retailer
you don't need to do that to know
whether you like something or you don't
like something you can do a sense check
with yourself
every single day after doing an activity
and if you literally after you did
anything anything you do stop and just
ask yourself
did i enjoy that yes or no simple
question so let's say i say yes
what did you enjoy about it let's have
that conversation what did i enjoy about
it
what part of it was uncomfortable but
you still got excited about it these are
three simple questions that can lead you
to greater self-awareness i've done the
same with every area of my life and you
should really become like an
encyclopedia in your own life like if
someone goes to what's your favorite
movie it's like i am a big fan of
thrillers my favorite director and
producer of all time is christopher
nolan my favorite
movies are memento the prestige
inception interstellar and the dark
knight trilogy they're all christopher
nolan movies it's there's such a pattern
in our lives and
everyone has that pattern we just have
to look beyond the debris
that's all there of the noise and the
the dirt that's stopping us because
there's just so much distraction
humility means to be honest it's like
the ability to say
this is what this person deserves credit
for and this is what i deserve credit
for and this is what this person it's
like it's kind of like when you write
the acknowledgements of your book
right you write yeah i mean you and i
and i remember doing that process and
really thinking about like who's helped
this book in different ways and everyone
gets their line in the acknowledgement
who's made a difference now your name
goes on the front cover because you
wrote the book
like you want everyone to receive the
credit to the degree they merit in yes
and so you never want someone to feel
like they didn't receive as much credit
as they deserve and at the same time you
don't want to give someone more credit
than they deserve the point of credit is
to give it where credit's due right and
so for me that's honesty that's humility
arrogance and pride is when you start to
feel like
only you did it on your own and we all
know that's just not true like i can't
say i did it all on my own i i just i
can't anyway i definitely can't say that
and i can't say it was all other people
and so that is the that's where honesty
and humility i think live together
either you're someone who finds it hard
to get motivated and productive and be
effective throughout the day you get
distracted or stuck or lost or maybe
you're someone who's ticking off
everything from your to-do list but are
feeling drained fatigued and
dissatisfied at the end of the day if
either of those are you this is the
video to watch the first piece of advice
i'm going to give you it's really simple
plan for a commute now for those of you
that are working from home you may be
wondering this doesn't apply to me jay
well actually it does
what i find is that if you create a 10
to 15 minute commute in your day
and instead of diving straight into work
waking up out of your bed walking to
your kitchen table you actually take a
walk around the block you're basically
tricking your mind to feel like you're
going somewhere one of the reasons why
we're all feeling so encaged and so
enclosed is because we don't feel like
we're changing environment we don't feel
like we're moving from place to place
like we were before so if that's your
case i want to make sure that you find
10 minutes at the beginning and the end
of the day to go to work and come back
from work and use that as time to
actually dive into a podcast an audio
book or a blink on blinkist whatever
works for you to give yourself some time
to prepare for work now i didn't always
love reading when i was growing up i
used to love playing video games i used
to love playing sports i used to like
listening to music and maybe playing
around with a few instruments when i
could but i didn't always love reading
and now i realize it's because i was
always exposed to lots of fiction books
at school we were taught to read fiction
books at college it was all about
fiction books and i realized for me
i really gravitated towards non-fiction
books autobiographies biographies and
self-help books i grew up in a house
where my father was either reading the
bhagavad-gita a book by deepak chopra
jim rohn or tony robbins and so i was
surrounded by these wisdom books and
that's where i found my love for reading
learning and growing one of the things i
fell in love with about non-fiction
books is that you didn't just read them
you could study them you could analyze
them you could extrapolate lessons and
practical action steps that would
transform your life and i really feel
that i've been a student of these books
for over the last 16 to 18 years of my
life and they have made a huge
difference i absolutely love reading
biographies and autobiographies one of
my favorite biographies is by walter
isaacson and it's steve jobs biography
if you haven't read it you have to go
and check it out and again when i typed
it on blinkist i was so happy to see
that they had such an incredible
breakdown of one of my favorite books
the three-piece methodology is fantastic
for biographies and autobiographies
because it helps you learn from people i
think it's so important to learn from
the lives of people that inspire us the
people that we admire the people that
we're intrigued by because guess what at
one point you're going to fail just like
them
and then you can think about what they
did
at one point you're going to have things
happen to you that you didn't plan for
and you'll need to know how to deal with
uncertainty and discomfort just like
they did find the people that are going
to champion you let them champion you
let them help you grow and you'll see
phenomenal things that happen in your
life don't give energy to areas that are
taking energy away because they're only
going to take more if someone's
criticizing you if someone's not with
you that's already extracting energy
then you focusing on that is giving up
more energy but when someone out there
supporting you they're championing you
they're giving you energy give that
energy back to them and see incredible
things happen that old story of how
there's a caterpillar
struggling to get out of its cocoon
and a young boy sees this
and he sees the struggle and he sees the
pain
and he thinks to himself i better help
this caterpillar out because he needs to
go off and become a big butterfly and so
the little boy breaks the cocoon
and by breaking the cocoon doesn't
realize the caterpillar also dies
because the caterpillar needed that
struggle
in order to become this beautiful
butterfly and so i really believe that
we've all been trapped in this cocoon
for the past five months and it's so
easy to want to now rush out the other
side and just break through and get on
with it
but i would say that a more steady
and more
uh self development approach to it which
is like let me learn through this time
let me really gain every lesson during
this time because that caterpillar
becomes a beautiful butterfly the other
side every time
when they allow themselves to go through
the process but when they try and jump
the process skip the process someone
helps them break the process
it can end actually completely the
opposite way and so i think nature
is is always showing us how to deal with
transformation and how to deal with
a pain and how to deal with
negative situations and struggle and no
matter how struggling it is the biggest
mistake humans make is that we try and
rush out of pain out the other side and
that's kind of what happened with a few
weeks ago at least in the united states
people try to rush out of their homes
because five months have been too long
and then all the numbers went up again
and so that's what happens every time we
try and rush out of a painful situation
it's almost like let's just build up
that extra piece of resilience that
extra and i know it's hard i get it i
know how painful it is but it's like
that is gonna create less pain in the
future and and i think that's what we
have to keep uh putting that yardstick
of like we have to realize that
it's better to go through that
uh consistent definite struggle that
we're going through but for a future
that we really want to create living
when we start doing something for
nothing we break the cycle so i was
speaking at a conference last week
and i had a very senior partner at a
firm come up to me and he said to me you
know what you talked about service you
talked about doing something for nothing
you talked about how
happiness
neuroscientifically is wired we're wired
for generosity we're talking about the
brain we're talking about science here
we're not just talking about some nice
sentiments we're not just talking about
some nice statements by some
philosophers those philosophical
statements are true we're now backing
them up by science
he he said to me he goes you know what i
never thought that life was beyond my
self-centered journey until i had
children he said that was the first time
i realized that my life was more than
just about me
and i was thinking why wait that long
if we don't have to why wait that long
to recognize that actually we can be
happier more fulfilled have an impact
make a change in people's lives earlier
on by accepting that so if you've got
kids you can start now anyway but if you
haven't start now we can start this
habit as early on as possible we don't
have to wait and we break the cycle when
we change it when i worked in the
corporate firms i recognized that when a
new person joined whether there was an
analyst or an associate or a new person
joined they would naturally get all
the the crap right they'd get the
rubbish they'd they'd have to do all the
pick-me-up stuff
they'd have to pick up the pieces of
someone else's work they wouldn't get
any exciting projects the funny thing
was when that analyst that associate
grew to the next level they treated
their junior person joining their team
in exactly the same way
that pattern continued guess what when
that person got promoted they treated
their junior in exactly the same way and
guess what that cycle just repeated
itself i want to break that cycle right
i want to break that cycle i want us to
be a part of breaking that cycle in
society because we can do it all of us
together if one of us breaks that cycle
imagine the domino effect that have
imagine how exponentially that grows
when one person decides to do something
differently if we just look at the
example
just to look at it in context or not in
context but looking at a huge example of
this when one person makes a difference
you look at someone like rosa parks the
difference that rosa parks had
right on the bus imagine that what it
takes imagine how exponentially that's
grown and it's and all we're saying is
give acts of kindness we're saying let's
not treat people badly let's not
continue that cycle let's actually break
that cycle you want to make sure that in
any habit change there is some reward
and a reward is making sure you
recognize what amazing growth you're
making that you're taking a moment to
see look how far i've come because our
mind again tricks us and always goes
look how far you have to go it's really
important that you remind yourself of
how far you've come how much you've
grown the difference you've made ego
is demonstrated in two ways so ego is
either i am the best in the world and i
think i'm better than everyone
or ego says you're the worst in the
world you're the worst than everyone
you're you're much worse than everyone
or you say my life is the best and the
greatest
my life is the worst right my life is
far worse than anyone else so the ego
likes to push you to the extreme it
doesn't like to give you balance and
honesty and reality it likes to it wants
to make you feel like you've got the
worst life in the world and no one else
understands it no one gets there only
you get in you get the worst or you're
the best and no one else gets you you're
untouchable
and and people miss that they're like
how does that make sense exactly like
you said but it does make sense because
the ego wants to be the top
or the bottom but the top of the bottom
yes it doesn't just want to be at the
bottom
of the bottom yeah it's going to be the
bottom of the bottom of the bottom but
the top of the bottom right right
yeah and so we get lost in that and we
don't think of it as ego yeah and that's
why the only antidote to either ego
is self-honesty
is being honest and honesty is i'm good
at these things i'm great at these
things and i suck at these things right
that's honestly like and we could all
sit down me and you could sit down with
a list of our skills
and map out what we were great at what
we were average at and what we knew we
were terrible at yes and that's honesty
that keeps you so away from either ego
one of the greatest rules for change
that i think is not given enough focus
is that change can never happen
if someone has to lose
right if someone has to lose in creating
a change that's not changed change is a
win win for everyone and we've heard
this in the you know i think it's in the
seven habits of highly effective people
a win-win is like you know think win win
but but what i'm saying is
when you're trying to create a change
don't look at it as like i'm right and
that person's wrong as soon as you
create that what you've done is you've
not created a change you've created
division
yes and so what we have to do is how do
we create a new platform whereby both
people are growing above right and wrong
where there's movement above right and
wrong right and wronger are
stagnant places in places that cause
division but when you talk about a
movement as you mentioned that comes
when we go beyond right and wrong and we
go this is the direction we need to go
in as a society that's hard to do
but it really is the truth of change
like the rule of change is stop trying
to make someone wrong because that means
you're right well guess what if they're
right now you're wrong
and and that's that's never going to
create a harmonious society what we need
is where we all go actually
let me understand let me listen let me
really understand why that person thinks
that way and it's not that you agree
with them it's not that you think
they're right it's that you have to give
it a chance i remember when we were i
used to be on my debating society uh at
school i was super dorky and geeky and
uh i loved loved debating society and i
remember the first rule of debate
was that you could not debate someone if
you didn't fully understand their
emotion in their side
that was the first rule if you did not
understand their motion and their
perspective you couldn't you weren't
allowed to debate because then you were
just debating based on ego
and i think that's the thing that's
misleading us is that we're fighting
based on our ego and this desire to be
right and make stuff happen rather than
fighting from a place of compassion
which which wants collective growth not
just individual growth in life there are
two aspects that impact everything our
thinking and our actions
and i read a quote the other day that
was saying that the mistake we make is
that we either act without thinking or
we think without acting and i think
that's where most people are if you're
feeling stuck or you're like i'm not
sure what i'm doing right now you're
either doing too much thinking or you're
doing too much acting so you're just
doing a lot of stuff but you don't know
why you're doing it or you're just
sitting there procrastinating every day
and you're doing it so i'd say it's both
so the first thing i would say to you
is take a moment
and speak to three different people
speak to a family member a friend and a
colleague and ask them this one question
what strengths do i have what do you
think is my superpower what skills do
you think i bring emotional strong soft
hard whatever it is
do that first get that sense check
second thing for the next month take off
every weekend eight days because there's
eight saturdays and sundays all together
in a month
and book a different course workshop
seminar online offline go to an event
shadow a friend go and spend time with
an aunt uncle who's doing the career you
want go and have eight new experiences
and after each of them sit with yourself
and ask yourself
did i like that yes or no
whether you like to or ask yourself why
did i like it or why did i not like it
and then ask yourself would i like to do
it again
and if the answer is yes yes yes guess
what go do it again and if the answer is
no no no don't do it again leave it out
but if you've had eight and this is the
problem we do that over a year we do
that over eight years and that's why
life feels slow and boring and lethargic
and stuck but it just in the next eight
days in a weekend just test eight new
things and you'll have just a great
experiment and the worst thing that will
happen is you'll find eight things that
you don't like but i guarantee you that
even if you have a sense of that
reflection in the beginning and and what
i don't get why we don't do this enough
is wow we do it with food and movies all
the time like you just
ed is such a kind man like i got here
slightly late because of traffic and
then he let me eat my lunch because i
wanted to be full of energy i i need to
find out where that place is because
it's local to here my my team got it
ordered for me it was amazing
and it's like you know when you eat
something whether you like it or not you
know when you watch a movie whether you
like it or not you know when you read a
book whether you like it or not
but why don't we ask ourselves after
meeting people completing projects or
going to places most of us keep meeting
people that take our energy most of us
keep going to places that drain us of
our energy and most of us keep working
on projects
that just disturb our energy
all you have to do is ask yourself
does this bring me alive
why does it bring me alive really
important to know why it works and do i
want to do it again i really believe
brendan that we have a very limited
emotional vocabulary so when someone
says we use five words okay
good
bad fine hmm right like how's your day
going okay how's your weekend good how's
that project fine right and so
we don't even understand how we feel so
how someone else can understand how we
feel so the emotional vocabulary by
harvard does is that it shows you the
top word of say sad and then it shows
you almost
an extension of what are you really
feeling when you're sad are you upset
are you offended are you disappointed
are you disheartened are you heartbroken
there are so many more words so this is
what it means to think like a monk where
you diagnose
how you genuinely feel and then you
clearly articulate that so that not only
are you asking for the right thing
people really understand you and that's
one of the biggest mistakes in
relationships we we don't really know
what we're asking for one of the best
things i like to talk about
is just small acts of kindness right
small acts of kindness
and
throw gratitude round like it's confetti
right throw kindness and gratitude
around like they're confetti like when
you've got confetti when you've got a
wedding or a party or whatever it is you
just you just sprinkle on everyone it's
exciting to throw it on everyone you see
that sprinkle where it falls on their
hair maybe if they're too
if they're too conscious about their
hair they may not like it right but
we enjoy that feeling and we need to do
the same with kindness and gratitude and
that's something we can do all day just
small thank yous to everyone
appreciating people being grateful to
people you know just keeping the door
open for individuals asking people if
they need a hand with something that
they're doing there are so many
unlimited opportunities in a day
to express kindness
if that's what you want now i'll give
you an example when i was on my flight
here from new york on tuesday i was
flying over from london back to new york
and when i was flying over i'd forgotten
to book myself a vegan meal on the
flight now when that happens i usually
end up having to starve because they
don't necessarily have any other options
but the amazing thing is
that the
uh the stewardess was so nice she was
she was extremely kind she was she was
like don't worry that you haven't booked
it it happens all the time and she went
as far as offering me her own meal
because that was the only meal that i
could eat on the plane now i declined i
politely declined but i was so touched
right she didn't have to do that she was
actually going to give up her own meal
so that i could eat when when that was
packed for her and it was actually my
fault that i'd forgotten to book my own
meal and i was touched by that you know
i was just like wow that's so kind of
you and so obviously i declined i didn't
want to steal her meal and i'd luckily
pack some lunch because i know that i'm
terrible at booking these kind of things
and so in the end and i took out some
stuff then she told me that actually she
was trying to be vegan etc so i shared
one of my and she said the reason why
she's struggling is because she loves
chocolate so i shared one of my
these these homemade chocolate uh cakes
thing i think it was a chocolate brownie
i shared it with and she was really
happy and i was just thinking it was
such a small insignificant act of
kindness it took no effort it took no
meaning it wasn't difficult i was on a
flight but that reciprocal exchange
starts bringing that domino effect where
we start making kindness exponential
right we let kindness escalate
throughout the world we have to become
proactive and not reactive in our giving
i remember there was a time when
literally every week every month i'd get
a new notification from a friend saying
that they were just giving they were
running for a marathon they were trying
to raise some money for charity they
were doing all these different things
and
you know you get a little thing that
says fill this out please donate some
money now most of us do that in an
office setting in a work setting in a
social setting more it's what i call
guilt giving as opposed to compassionate
caring right it's not proactive
purposeful
support it's guilt-giving you feel
guilty you think oh god if everyone in
the office gives and i don't give how
are they gonna feel or you know everyone
in my family is giving ten dollars and
i'm not giving ten dollars and that
actually reduces the passion and the
purpose and the love we get from giving
that reduces that
generosity because we're wired for
generosity we're not wired to be forced
to give we're not wired to guilt giving
so recognize that when you feel yourself
guilt-giving make the switch think
actually if i'm giving this
ask yourself am i giving for a purpose i
know about see there's levels in which
you can give as well if you give without
even knowing where it's going you give
without how the person is going to use
it that's not going to fulfill you
that's not going to help you grow but if
you know
where that money is going if you know
what use it's going to if you actually
get involved and put time into a
homeless shelter helping the elderly
helping children whatever it may be when
you start getting more conscious about
the way you give you will start to see
the difference so be proactive don't be
reactive not just when your friend's a
marathon if you're only given that way
you're nurturing guilt-giving not
compassionate i really recommend that
you look at something where you know you
have an impact on people's lives look at
your career think of what skills you
have i guarantee you there's somewhere
out there someone that can benefit with
that skill if you just took it to the
streets once a month and the
satisfaction what's that video find the
do something for nothing campaign what's
their video all it takes is a small act
of kindness going out in the streets
taking your skills to the streets
sharing them with someone sharing them
with people trying to help organizations
psychologically we feel a sense of
safety and security
when we think people agree with us
right that is just psychologically true
that i we would rather avoid conflict
and sit in a space where we agree
and therefore we have something called
confirmation bias
and the echo chamber
where we keep surrounding ourselves with
thoughts and ideas that are similar and
reaffirm our beliefs
now i think that you can have that and
at the same time entertain ideas that
you're not sure about yet and so one of
my favorite examples was mit did this
study where they asked people
which person was more creative and
innovative and they showed two charts
one chart was employee a and the other
chart was employee b
the chart for employee a
all of the people they knew
knew each other and knew them back so it
was almost like a closed loop
and employee b they knew lots of people
who didn't know each other
and they found that people who have more
people in their network who don't know
each other are more likely to be
creative and productive really yeah
because they expose you to opposing
ideas
and they may counteract how you think so
one of my favorite examples of this
is a conversation between
mark zuckerberg and one of his mentors
so mark zuckerberg told this story
at the facebook headquarters a few years
back i wasn't there i've seen it on
video i'm sure it's available and he
talks about how when he was struggling
with the direction of facebook in 2009
he approached his mentor and his mentor
happened to be steve jobs wow pretty
cool wow pretty cool i wish really yeah
it's so cool man and so anyway so mark
zuckerberg goes to steve jobs and he
says i'm struggling with the direction
of facebook remember at that time
facebook was five years old there was no
fan pages i don't think i don't i don't
think it was there was no creators there
was i don't think there were fan pages
it was very much used by university
students at that stage like i think it
was mainly like ivy leagues
college kids and i don't even think it
was international in a massive way very
early days and now we can't even think
of that but 2009 i mean
you know you just about had the iphone
and just about had instagram on youtube
so he ran up to steve jobs and he said
you know i'm struggling with the
direction of facebook what do i do
now steve jobs at that time obviously
was already
the founder of one of the biggest brands
on the planet and obviously the brand
still is
he had access to investors he had access
to business coaches i'm sure he had
access to life coaches he had access to
health experts everything he had access
to anything like i don't think there was
any scientists scientists phds i don't
think there's anyone in the world who
steve jobs couldn't have called up at
the time
and steve jobs said something amazing he
said you know what mark i think you
should go
and live in an ashram in india he did
not he did oh
he goes anywhere you go to live in the
ashram in india
that's where if you spend some time
there that's where you'll find your
answer shut up and mark did it no way
went to the ashram it's a true story a
lot i i believe he was there for i
believe i've seen two online i've seen
two versions of the exact time he was
there i've seen some people said it was
a couple of days or a week or some
people said it's a month so i think it's
it's hazy how much time he actually
spent there but but he went
and he says that based on that
experience that's where he found the
direction of facebook to be connecting
people
now the reason why i love that story is
because
it's the unobvious alternative
random connection and when harvard did a
study of 3 000 executives they looked at
and asked them what's the number one
skill for being a good leader
and a lot of people would say
communication a lot of people would say
vision strategy humility and the number
one answer that they got from 3000
executives
was the one word which is called
associating and what that means is the
ability to spot patterns where everyone
else doesn't see them
and that's the connect that
real leaders can spot
patterns and connections in anomalies so
most people be like what is an ashram
got to do with a tech platform right but
that is where you expand your mind to
find answers that you never expected no
one had
the guidebook for 2020 up their sleeve
or no one could even have expected
themselves to be ready for this like no
matter how good you are at predicting or
trends or whatever it is
99 of people did not see this coming and
so there needs to be a bit of
self-compassion and not judging
ourselves it's so easy to get into that
spiral of one of the pieces of
negativity is judgment of self like
judging ourselves for not being the best
parents not being the best partners not
being the best people and that's how to
get out of jail free card to behave how
you want what that is
genuinely allowing yourself to say hey i
need a bit of time just to adapt and be
compassionate because
no one had the mindset or the plan no
this this is a black swan event
yeah this is this is crazy and so it's
so extreme
but what should happen
and we were talking about this earlier
brendan is that in this moment you now
shift to go okay i get it i'm going to
build the muscles that are going to help
me build adaptability and resilience for
this forever so i'm never going to be
blindsided again or i never want to be
in a situation again where i don't have
the tools so when you're thinking like a
monk for this situation and the
negativity the first thing that a monk
does is it's about putting on your own
protective shield
a lot of us walk out onto the
battlefield of life without having done
our own training and our own uh
shielding and our own protection
and so one of the ways or a very simple
practical way you can transform your
environment is a 3s model that i give in
the book and it cites scents and sounds
now sight sense and sounds have a huge
impact on your personal shield and the
strength of your shield and so when we
look at site sites is what you see so
the big question i'd ask brendan anyone
who's listening or watching right now
is what's the first thing you see in the
morning
if it's your phone and studies show that
80 of people see their phone before
their partner in the morning and the
evening brendan right can you imagine
yeah the phone is the last thing you see
in the first thing you see in the
morning when you wake up when you do
that i would be awful
i was awful too i mean i you know this
is the point that you can't
put yourself in a uh you know something
often says like you know monks are not
training in a strip club then you don't
put yourself in the the complete extreme
opportunity sorry for my crudeness but i
love it i love it
you're not putting yourself in an
environment where you're set up to lose
when you're training
right when you're strong you can put
yourself in extreme environments
you make it you make it yourself work so
if you're waking up in the morning
make the first thing you see be a quote
you love
make it be a work of art that inspires
you maybe a picture of your family that
really means something to you but make
it the first thing you see it could be
on your bedside table it could be at
your ceiling wherever it is that you
look first make it something that makes
you pause
because otherwise when you dive into
your phone you're now reacting to
everyone's agenda everyone's focus the
news the negativity and you're now
starting your day with people filling
you up rather than you being an abundant
creator love that and so the first thing
i say is sight the second thing i'd say
is you've got to change your sounds in
your life and as monks
sound design was huge
so i discovered this when i lived in new
york city for two years and i used to
find myself feeling quite mentally tired
and i was always wondering what it was
so i started researching and reading as
we do and i read about this thing called
cognitive load and it was saying that
when you're processing insignificant
irrelevant sound
your brain is trying to process
something that doesn't actually have
meaning or use and so now you're wasting
80 percent of your brain's energy on
cognitive load so examples are having
the news on in the background
examples are being around culture where
there's a lot of noise and gossip
drilling construction work all of that
creates cognitive load now sound how can
you change it
we all know brendan and you do this at
your seminars beautifully you put on
music and everyone's jumping up and down
and sound has that energy
to change our physiology and has that
challenge sound as the opportunity to
change our biology and so for me
what sound are you playing in your work
environment is it the sound you want
intentionally what's the sound that you
wake up to by the way why does anyone
wake up to an alarm right
why would you bam
none of us would want to wake up to a
fire alarm so change the sounds that you
work to that you cook to that you sleep
to and you see your anxiety just
depreciate
and the third one is uh sense
i think scents are so underestimated
when you smell a food you love you're
already tasting it you're feeling it
you're feeling the benefit of it there's
a reason why when we walk into
a massage room and i remember when we
were in puerto rico we went for one of
those beautiful which you recommended to
me that i couldn't miss it it was one of
those treetop massages yeah
beautiful place and so i went for one of
those it's amazing but massage
parlors or spaces or whatever
spas or whatever they're called
they all have scents like lavender
eucalyptus sandalwood this isn't just
like to make you feel good for two
seconds when you breathe and inhale that
it reduces your
reaction the desire for negativity it
brings that positivity into your life so
if you're creating these habits in your
day
you'll find that the external negativity
is still there it's not changing it but
it's able to less penetrate your shield
how much of the world do you think we
receive
by being here and how much of the world
do we create ourselves yeah that's a
beautiful question it's it's a complete
dynamic dance
between
what the vedic tradition would call fate
and free will so fate is what is already
created for you
and a good example would be the place
you were born
the type of family you grew up in the
socio-economic background you had it was
already there when you walked in to the
world
but within that you had choices where
your free will came about
you had the choice to either do what
everyone in your neighborhood did or to
do something different you had the
choice
to have a relationship with a particular
person or not so what happens is that
we're constantly creating
new spaces from which we have another
choice right and so you kind of see as
this dynamic dance
between okay now i'm in this situation
and now what is my choice in this
situation so i would say i'm not saying
it's equal i'm saying it's a dynamic
balance and a switching process
where you're constantly creating a new
level and then now in that level you
have a next choice because we we didn't
have the choice to be created here we
didn't we were here and that wasn't our
choice
now everything after that is our choice
right yeah and there are some there
obviously there are some traditions and
i'm a big diver into like reincarnation
and past life so according to the
beliefs of reincarnation of past lives
you have at some point made a choice to
be here but
taking it more simplistically the truth
is that when you're brought into a
situation it's the best analogy that
i've heard and it's been told for years
is of a father is an alcoholic
one of the sons that he has decides to
become an alcoholic because his father's
an alcoholic
the other son decides to never drink
alcohol because his father's an
alcoholic right so they were exposed to
the same situation and same scenario
same environment same environment but
they both made different choices based
on their experience and that's the
choice element that's the element that
we should be trying to empower in our
lives because we can constantly say i'm
limited by my environment or i've been
restricted by my environment and hey
it's true there are so many of us that
have been limited and restricted but by
now you
repeating that you are going to repeat
that restriction in your life
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's fantastic
[Music]
amazing that was incredible
that was so good i would so do that
again that was incredible
oh my gosh thank you man
thank you
that was amazing
it worked out
and we talk a lot about today self-love
and self-care but i think you know a lot
of that starts with self-awareness which
we know about self-knowledge but
self-knowledge creates self-trust and a
lot of it's like learning to trust
ourselves and it's like if i don't know
what i love about myself how am i ever
going to trust myself how am i going to
trust that i have my best interest at
her
and so asking yourself what do you love
the number one skill
that keeps relationships together is not
uh date nights it's not movie nights
it's not uh beautiful vacations it's
knowing how to fight it's learning how
to manage a conflict because conflict is
always going to be there and most of us
don't have the skills or the emotional
capacity to to go there and we kind of
think that that's like a bad thing and i
think that's part of it brendan is that
movies and music and media have created
these
negative viewpoints in relationships
like you know the the end of a movie and
i'm sure this has been said a million
times but the end of a movie is always
happily ever after so it ends at the
beginning of the wedding right it's like
it's like they got married at the end of
a movie when for most love relationships
the marriage is the beginning of the
relationship
and so you're watching it only up until
the point two people fell in love and
they were happily ever after and i think
that's planted this seed in our mind oh
relationships have to look like
beautiful and wonderful and roses and
this and that is part of it i love that
i'm a hopeless romantic and i love all
of that stuff but at the same time it's
relationships require like real honesty
and transparency and
talking things out that are tough and
having those awkward conversations and
silences sometimes right who do i want
who is the person that i need to be
uh that i can love
that i want to love that i want to give
more love to like what parts of growth
are there still available and there's
one thing i want to add which isn't a
question but it has been a really
reaffirming or deepening affirmation for
me that i keep reminding myself and i
think it's helped a lot of people that
i've shared it with is literally some
days i'll just put my hand on my heart
and i'll just repeat to myself i'm
exactly where i need to be
and that's so true it's just such a
great reminder like if you literally put
your hand on your heart you just go i
am exactly where i need to be
you stop getting lost in the future you
stop worrying about the past and you
realize that everything you need to
learn everything you read right now to
make a change it's all right now it's
all right here and so that's one of my
favorite things to repeat it's not a
question but it's more of a mantra
saying we're always feeling like we're
we either feel like we're ahead
we feel like oh i'm doing better than
everyone i'm kind of like winning the
game or more often we feel behind where
we feel like oh they just got promoted
ah they just you know they got proposed
to whatever it is like we always feel
like they have their first child or
whatever their first child they uh
bought their first house whatever it is
and we're always feeling ahead or behind
and so when you say to yourself i'm
exactly where i need to be
you realize you're not a head or behind
and the problem is if you always think
you're a head or behind then you're
always comparing yourself to others
whereas if you're where you need to be
you now just need to get to the next
place of where you want to be yeah and
and also you only get ahead of yourself
by first being present with yourself
adam grant says in his book give and
take i definitely recommend reading it's
a great read adam grant give and take he
talks about integrating your interests
and skills with the needs of others we
start bringing those two things together
i often say your passion is for you your
purpose is for others he talks about the
need for integrating your interests and
skills with the needs of others right
selfless giving in the absence of
self-preservation
becomes overwhelming just focus on that
for a moment selfless giving in the
absence of self-preservation becomes
overwhelming so those are the two areas
if you want to be a giver
you've got to preserve yourself you've
got to refuel yourself you've got to
focus on yourself too
but that's the difference the motivation
for fueling yourself is so that you can
give that's what it means to do
something for nothing is that you're
constantly refueling re-energizing
preserving growing evolving becoming
stronger becoming better so that you can
give so that you can serve so that you
can be generous that's when we start
activating our lives to become
instruments of compassion we start
channeling a higher energy we start
channeling a greater meaning and purpose
in our lives and that's when what you do
becomes infectious people just meet you
and they think wow like what is it about
you that
that i'm so connected to what is it
about you that i'm so attracted to it's
that infectious desire to want to make a
difference in someone else's life
rather than just be growing yourself you
don't have to be perfect to inspire
others
you can inspire people by how you deal
with your imperfections
right you don't have to be perfect to
inspire others you can inspire people by
how you deal with your imperfections
none of us are perfect none of us can
claim to be perfect none of us can be
perfect all the time but the way we
monitor the way we grow the way we
evolve from our imperfections allows
others to feel inspired so you may be
thinking
i want to do small acts of kindness i
want to help other people i want to do
something for nothing
but my worry is that i'm not perfect i
don't have everything i'm not sure that
i'm complete i'm not sure i have
anything to give the truth is that
anything you give in that example will
have an impact that's so much about
doing something for nothing that
something doesn't have to be money it
doesn't have to be lots of money it
doesn't have to be lots of time it just
has to be love right imagine if
everything in life was infused with love
now call me an idealist but i'm okay
with that because i truly believe that
every intention
can be infused with love if you really
want it to be you and i know when you're
traveling
if your partner wants to tell you
something and you're living a hectic
busy life
your partner will be scared to actually
say brenda jay i really need to tell you
something because they just think you're
too busy and all over the place
your body and mind are the same way
your body your mind your soul they want
to communicate with you but they can't
communicate with you if you're always
rushing around and everywhere all over
the place so the answers the answers are
not within me the answers are within you
and they become more clearer as you
become more silent more still and allow
yourself to have that inner connection
from your inner guide i've realized that
those three years and i describe it this
way and the way you said it that the
three years being a monk were being at
school
and the last seven years since i've left
have been the exam
and i can genuinely say so far that
every tool that i have tested from my
monk toolkit works
and the biggest one or most most likely
the most powerful one that i felt is
there's a beautiful verse in the
i talk about in the book
and it says that
when you protect your purpose your
purpose protects you and what i mean by
that and i will broaden purpose to mean
what it needs to mean for anyone
listening
you have to protect
your strengths your calling your
passions your interests your skills you
have to protect them like a like a
precious jewel because the whole world
will come at you and tell you that it's
not a jewel the whole world will come at
you and tell you that it's worth nothing
and if you don't protect it it can't
protect your value back
and most of us as soon as we get
questioned we just chuck the jewel out
we just chuck it away and we go oh yeah
that wasn't worth anything
and then later on in life you realize
you threw away a precious jewel so i
love that verse because that's what i
was test being tested to do is i was
about to go sell myself short
and just go back into the world that i
came from and just chuck out that jewel
rather than like hey i learned all these
things i wanted to serve i became a monk
because i wanted to serve how can i
still serve how can i not just throw
that all out and pretend that it doesn't
matter and how can i apply the
discipline and the mentality and all of
the great skills because guess what when
surprise surprise no one wants to hire
someone with monk on their resume for
three years
and and that's what i had
because they couldn't see the
transferable skills i had to see them so
they were thinking oh he's probably just
gonna be really quiet in the office
right like what is he gonna do but i
knew that that choir was intuition i
knew that that choir was solitude not
loneliness i knew that that quiet was
the power that that ability to to to
read things to read in between the lines
to connect with people most of us are
asking for things
that aren't even clearly linked to what
we are actually missing
and so i'll give an example of this i
have so many clients that i coach or so
many people that i work with where the
number one thing they want from their
partner is time
and like i wish my partner had more time
brendan i i wish they just gave me more
time now the amazing thing is me and
brendan are giving each other time right
now but what if i was like this the
whole time right if brendan was writing
another best-selling book at this time
and and we kind of talked but imagine we
did that the whole time it looks like
you're present there with them
but
you're not when this is like this is
like a force field between you your
phone your your your task your thing i
love that time yeah that's so good this
could be a book this could be a
newspaper this could be email whatever
it is but it's interesting people say i
want more time and so people come back
from a weekend away
and then they'll go back to their pond
and be like i wish we spent more time
together and the other partner is going
well we just went over on a weekend and
they're thinking but no but you were at
the beach and i was with the kids and it
that wasn't so what are people really
asking for i've realized that over this
time people are asking for three things
and they're asking for time they're
asking for presents
they're asking for attention and they're
asking for intimacy that is what people
are actually asking for beautiful say
the word time and so we re we
misunderstand it we truly have influence
in our more than our environment our
environment affects us for sure it
plants seeds and weeds into our life but
there is still a choice
and and i think even if you feel there
isn't a choice
simply by accepting that there is it
means you have a chance to get out of
there and i think that's what because if
you don't accept that there is then
you're just going to stay stuck correct
like there's been so many times in my
life and there's a beautiful
quote from edison
i don't think i said this last time but
if i did it's worth repeating he said
that when you believe you've exhausted
all options remember this you haven't
and the reason why i love that is your
mind continuously feels stuck when it's
tried the obvious and that's why a lot
of creativity and focus studies say that
the first 10 ideas that come to your
mind are never the most interesting it's
when you get into the 11th idea that you
start breaking the pattern and so if
someone asks you oh what's your best
business idea your first 10 ideas are
probably not that innovative and so the
mind constantly gets stuck on that train
and you've got to keep reminding
yourself that there is another door
there could be another pathway i was
thinking about a piece of advice that so
one of my closest spiritual mentors who
is in london
i knew him since i was probably like 12
and probably went since i was 18. he
passed away this year from stage four
brain cancer
and he'd had brain cancer for about i
think like three
three four years now and so i hadn't
really had a real interaction with him
for the past few years because every
time i saw him he wasn't fully
functioning in his short-term memory his
long-term memory was there but his
short-term memory wasn't
and i remember speaking to him probably
about seven eight years ago
and asking him the question i said to
you know i've got so many ideas there's
so many things i could do
where do i start
and he said this beautiful thing to me
he said you know what your role should
be to open up every door possible
and he said let the world close the
doors you're not meant to walk through
and walk through the ones that remain
open
and what i realize is most of us just
not opening up enough doors because we
think we only have the option of two
doors we look at life as binary zero and
one zero and one right it's just there's
a b this or that and i mean i i think
you'd say this too about you and every
guest you've ever had on
i don't think life is ever this or that
it's like this that and that and maybe
that and that and there's always a gap
let's take that sales person
the more time that person spends
in empathy
their customers pain
and what the customer is really looking
for
the better they're going to be received
yes
so that service mindset always helps
because if you're thinking about and
this is what it comes and i said this to
my team when we were writing the book
and everything i was working on i said
if i sit here right now
and all i'm thinking about while i'm
writing the book is being a best-selling
book
then guess what i'm now not writing the
book i'm now living in the future and
i'm not living in the present and so the
only way to make this a best-selling
book is to do the process properly and i
don't think and this is what i do and
this is the only thing that's helping me
and again i go through all the time
after my first video went viral three
four years ago
i stopped creating because of the
pressure that i wouldn't be able to live
up to it
so i actually got scared because i was
like oh well what if the next video
doesn't do as well everyone's going to
think i'm tanking like you get into that
self-doubt and that self and i got into
that space where i was just thank you
for being honest about it yeah no really
like genuinely i didn't want to make a
video again because i was like this
video just got 40 million views like how
am i ever gonna beat that right and you
get scared i'm not putting anything out
i'm just gonna stop and then i started
to realize i was like well now i'm not
living in service anymore
i'm living out of ego and i'm living for
feeling a certain way and guess what i'm
not feeling better by not putting
anything out yeah and actually if i just
serve more i'll learn more so the way
i've made sense of it and there's a
verse in the gita that explains it too
is that you have full control over the
preparation
the process
and the practice
but you have no control
over the potential result but all of
those three things are the result in and
of themselves and so if you get addicted
to the process of writing the practice
of connecting with the right people who
can help share your work
and hey like you said i am focused on
the process of making sure that the most
people in the world have the opportunity
to buy this book
but then if they choose not to buy it i
can't control that but i can control
making sure that it's in front of
everyone and that i believe in the
context and that to me is not attachment
that to me is not uh ego that to me is
trying to live your best life i mean
like you know if you didn't just try if
you're like i read this book but who
cares yes i mean that's not service
either because the way i explain it and
i'm not i'm not claiming that this is it
and i'm not trying to say i'm it i'm
trying to say that
i think we all feel this way
if
you or me see an amazing movie we want
to tell everyone about it
if you read an amazing book you want to
tell everyone about it if you found the
cure to cancer you tell everyone about
it for me i got to live an incredible
life thanks to these amazing teachers i
met
i just want to tell everyone about it
like that's all i'm doing yes but i want
to tell everyone because of how powerful
it was sports is great mental training
because you have to show up to the next
game even if you lost and you don't feel
bad exactly that you don't feel good
sorry and and one of the things before i
dive into that question one of the
things that you reminded me of was that
the last dance documentary so there's
that season
that michael jordan everyone is
agreement in an agreement that he is one
of the best players
to be playing and they keep losing they
didn't make the fight they didn't make
the finals they lost
and then they realized they need to get
the team and they need to find i think
they bring in dennis rodman and then
start bringing in all these other
players that strengthen whereas if they
would have just said oh we got the best
player in the world we just keep doing
this
i'm not sure what they would have got
there right but the coach phil jackson
and the team they had to adapt and so
you're saying why do we feel that pain
in rejection and how do we deal with
that
i think we feel that pain because we
look at a failure
right we look at it as a complete
definition of us
right we're looking at it as as there's
that famous statement of like you know
failure is an event not a person
right and i don't know who said it but
it's one of those statements that that
really clicks like failure is uh an
event not a person whereas we start
thinking we are the failure like we say
i am a very
exactly right like i those are the words
i am a failure i
got rejected
and it's like no your application got
rejected okay your efforts your effort
your specific effort at this moment in
time got rejected your specific exam at
this point got failed you didn't you are
not a failure and so you have to
disconnect and distance yourself from
the event
so i end up creating this social media
role at accenture where i'm creating all
of this content i'm learning how the
biggest brands in the world use social
media i'm working with executives on
social media presence and understanding
twitter and linkedin and i just get
exposed to this incredible world and
that's where i get to learn these skills
i never created
you know viral content while i was at
accenture but it just started opening up
my mind to what was possible right it
was just like oh these are the tools
feeling comfortable with failure getting
it wrong it gave me a playground right
it gave me an opportunity and this is
what anyone who's listening in
to this right now watching this and
you're working at a company your company
is giving you an opportunity to learn to
grow to test i learned so much about
digital and strategy working at
accenture that i could never have got
from reading a book or or going to a
course or seminar because it was there
like i was i was there with it every day
with a company that was 500 000 people
you know a global organization so
that's when when i hear that people are
dissatisfied with their jobs and their
companies my biggest question is have
you learned everything you possibly
could from that place
because the truth is you could find a
lot more meaning and passion in a place
that you don't want to be in
because you realize it could be
the answer and key to what you could do
in the future
and there is so much to gain yeah that's
a cool lens so the beautiful thing about
monk life is half the day is self and
half the day is service that's how
you're taught to live okay so the
morning hours are for you to fill
yourself it's almost like putting on
mental emotional and physical armor like
that's what a morning routine is our
days are tiring our days are busy our
days are draining well guess what if you
didn't put your armor on in the morning
and you're going out to battle
how many knives are gonna cut you how
many swords are to pierce you how many
wounds are you going to come home with
how many of you come back home feeling
wounded
i come back home feeling wounded
sometimes but guess what if you put your
armor on in the morning a warrior would
never go out onto a battlefield
and life can be a battlefield work can
be full of conflict sometimes your
relationships can be damaging sometimes
your friendships can be toxic sometimes
so we are
warriors in one sense
and so without wearing that so for me a
morning routine is putting on emotional
armor
which is meant to protect you for the
rest of the day and that way even if you
do get pierced or you do get popped or
you do get cut
you're protected
and i know that when my morning routine
is at its best i feel protected
whereas when my morning routine is
weakened i feel weak
and so for me the morning routine as i
get strategic about it there's two
principles you have to know
location has energy and time has memory
if you do something in the same place
every day that place now
holds that energy
and this is huge like it's it's just so
big and i'm grateful for that reaction
because people don't realize how how
powerful this is like when i meditated
in temples that were 5 000 years old in
south india
it was easier to meditate because people
have been meditating there for thousands
of years
and so when you find a space in your
home and even if you've got like i lived
in a 500 square foot apartment in new
york
four years ago
and i just had a tiny corner which i
dedicated to my sacred practices so if
you you don't have to have a big home to
do this you don't have to be wealthy to
do this you can find just a corner in
your home that you dedicate your
meditation space or your reflection
space so first thing location has energy
second thing
time has memory
and this is something that people
underestimate when you do something at
the same time every day
you remember it
and time remembers it that's why we
struggle to work out at different times
every day it's why we struggle like why
do we feel hungry at the same time every
day
generally we feel hungry at the same
time most people if you've got a
regulated diet you will feel hungry you
will feel tired at the same time every
day you will look towards that coke can
or that sugar or that chocolate bar at
the same time every day
and so when you're meditating at the
same time if you're exercising at the
same time so what i recommend to people
wow is your morning routine needs four
aspects and it's simple and i call it
time it's about making time in the day
okay so time stands for t i m e
t stands for thankfulness
there needs to be
even if it's five minutes five minutes
of thankfulness of gratitude every
single morning and that has to be
gratitude that's specific
it can't be gratitude that's generic so
generic gratitude is something that
anyone could be grateful for oh i'm
grateful for the sky i'm grateful for
air i'm grateful for water that's cool
but it's generic gratitude
specific gratitude is i'm grateful for
the fact that i have someone calling me
this morning i'm grateful for the fact
that i can still call my parents i'm
grateful for the fact that i have this
person in my business who is having such
an impact i'm grateful you know it's
specificity yeah so thankfulness second
one is insight i think this is one thing
that a lot of people are missing which i
recommend people listening to you it's
like podcasts books and and make it
easier for yourself if you get this book
leave it open on your bedside table
leave it open on your kitchen table
leave it open on your dining table i
guarantee you you will read more and
what you read will speak to you and i
think people underestimate that that
literally like when you have it open and
you just flick to a chapter randomly and
you pick up one line it will impact you
and it'll speak to you so insight you
need insight every day m is meditation
and i believe meditation is different
for different people as monks we did
walking meditations we did beach
meditations we did visualizations we did
breath work find your meditation
practice i give a ton in the book and
fourth obviously exercise which you can
speak to even more than i can i exercise
to keep fit you look amazing too though
but it's an exercise everyone needs to
find five minutes a day 15 minutes a day
of exercise you are integral
to making change like you're powerful if
you focus in on your environment if you
connect to becoming the best in that
space you are an incredible asset to
yourself to a team to other people to
anyone because all of these are needed
but the worst thing is when we try to do
someone else's duty and there's this
great verse in the bhagavad-gita which i
read as a monk which says that it's
better to do your own nature
even if only 50 than doing another ones
perfectly when we aim to do someone
else's work even perfectly
we'll always be challenged we'll always
be let down that's why we feel stressed
that's why we feel pressure in life
when you're doing pressure in your own
environment you feel the pressure but
you get through it you dive through it
kelly mcgonagall talks about that in a
book called the upside of stress that
when you're working in your passion
stress doesn't feel like stress anymore
you still experience it it just doesn't
feel like it but when you're not working
in your passion stress feels like stress
pressure feels like pressure it gets
really really heavy and we all
experience that in our lives and if
you're experiencing that in your career
you're experiencing that in your life
find areas of your day where you can be
pursuing your passion
fridge inspire me do something
i like following instructions i'm going
to follow your questions i'm going to
follow this word for word
[Music]
is this still edible
i'm so glad i make videos for a living
yeah we've got peppers we've got
jalapenos
got this
[Music]
great
[Music]
i have no idea what i'm doing but
i don't even know if this is enough
stuff
oh wow
oh crap
so there's a lot of new processes for me
right now there's
there's using a blender it's using an
oven it's using like whatever like it's
like
made with love
right
all right going in
ready lunch is ready
okay i'm so excited
so would you oh my gosh you actually
made the pepper
that looks so good
oh my gosh it's all actually
look how well you presented it try it
try it right there yeah okay let me try
it it actually looks so well presented
like i am so impressed
peppers jalapenos genuinely if i was
making it i'd want it to be this flavor
it tastes so good does it really no like
actually tastes so good you wanna try
some okay
[Music]
oh wow it tastes so good isn't it
i'm well impressed great job
it was really good
i was not expecting it to taste that
good so now he's gonna cook me meal
every week
[Music]
give me a day off
okay how much are you gonna put on me
is there a need like when would you put
this on in the day i like cleansing my
face at night
is it cold it's very hard cleansing is
actually meant to be a very
mindful activity okay go on make it
mindful just be quiet would you uh will
you do this for me every day when we're
at home absolutely not are you doing
just for the video just for the video
there you go
lovely all right you look brand new
okay so what do we do now so now we have
to get a hose
oh it's so cold
i have no idea what's going on you look
great that kind of feels like it's off
it's actually up
yeah it's tough enough how's it off
yeah but now you how is that now you dry
it ready
how does it feel
it feels really nice does it feel really
smell nice i feel refreshed
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because
you are awesome if you want some amazing
motivation from tony robbins check out
the video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there don't you have bad
days don't you have days when you're
like frustrated exiled and pissed off
and you watch tv and you eat cheetos and
watch pornography and i said well i do
some of those things right
and of course i do